so let's play a little better worse of
the same for some of these off-season
upgrades or not that teams have made and
it sounds like we both agree with joe
staley out and trent williams in with
the 49ers that's definitely an upgrade
it is it's better yes you know and again
we both respect joe staley we realize
the great player he is but you know mike
this is trent williams this is one of
these guys that ever since this these
problems have a arose in washington
you've heard me say this is special left
tackle this is a first ballot hall of
fame left tackle he is that type of guy
you know so i really kind of agree with
everything scott mccloughan said in his
little quote you know williams when
healthy and hidden on all cylinders he's
the best left tackle in the nfl
yeah i i agree with you and i think it
is a major upgrade for
the the san francisco 49ers and and
another reason to think that they're
going to pick up right where they left
off last year as one of the dominant
teams in the nfc all right cowboy's
defensive line chris you've been
critical of the defensive performance
last year by the cowboys offense good
defense didn't hold up its end of the
bargain for a team that went eight and
eight michael bennett malik collins and
robert quinn are out gerald mccoy dawn
terry poe aldon smith subject to
reinstatement by the commissioner is in
do you see that as better same or worse
i you know
this is a close one i think i'm going to
stay around i'm going to go with same
here i am you know first off
the the key player that was lost there
and the biggest name on that list is
robert quinn i mean robert quinn is a
special edge pass rusher the cowboys
lost him you're not going to say like
tick for tack like aldon smith for
robert quinn no definitely not now
listen with michael bennett and malik
collins you know getting gerald mccoy
don terry poe in there you know michael
bennett it's towards the end of his
career i'm not so sure it's not done if
not we don't see maybe we see one more
year you know malik collins good not
great so you know i don't know if there
was i think they might have improved the
interior part of the d-line but got
worse on the edge there and that's why
i'm gonna say the same
yeah you know and for me the wild card
in all of this is alden smith who's
reinstated
is still pending
um stephen jones told me a week and a
half ago that alton smith had had his
meeting with the commissioner so we wait
and this is one of the problems i have
with the reinstatement process there's
no timeline there's no standards the
commissioner has full discretion and the
commissioner can can decide whenever he
wants to decide they also have randy
gregory caught up in the reinstatement
effort as well but if alton smith if
alton smith is i don't know 75 percent
of the
and we know it's five years right he's
probably not going to be 75 of what he
was five years ago but the guy was so
damn good that if they can get him back
and if they can coax anything out of him
like what we saw earlier in his career
and he was drafted in 2011 i mean it's
not like it's 15 years ago i mean the
guy should still have some gas in the
tank physically they get him into shape
my goodness it could be better i think
that that to me the final verdict hinges
on can they get aldon smith back and
will he be uh the guy anywhere close to
what he was all right the houston texans
out our receiver deandre hopkins and
running back carlos hyde in receiver
randall cobb receiver brandon cooks and
running back david johnson better worse
of the same
well it's it's a two for three swap here
right and you know because of that third
extra player i'll say the same i mean to
me it's like brandon cooks and randall
cobb are almost equal to a one deandre
hopkins i mean that's really kind of the
way i look at it to a degree carlos hyde
who was nice to that football team last
year you know
no he's not as talented as david johnson
when david johnson's healthy now that's
a big question there so i'm saying the
same again here uh
this is it's another tough one i mean it
really is but i think when i look at
randall cobb and brandon cooks
for deandre hopkins i think two equals
one there and i like the potential of
david johnson and how he'll work in that
offense and he's certainly a more
talented player than carlos hyde the
injury thing i know is a question mark
no doubt about it but i'm gonna say the
same one more time
i'm not buying your two equals one thing
unless you're allowed to have 12 guys on
the field when brandon cooks and randall
cobb line up because deandre hopkins is
that guy who basically gives you 12 guys
on the field because you got to use two
guys to stop him and it opens it up for
everyone else between brandon cooks and
randall cobb i don't know that i'm going
to be as afraid of the texans offense as
i was afraid of it when deandre hopkins
was there all due respect to brandon
cooks i mean the guy's been hot potatoed
around the league pick first round pick
first round pick now
oh god it's only a second round pick now
or whatever it was that the texans gave
up to get him um i'm concerned about
cook's health i'm concerned about his
effectiveness he's not deandre
hopkins i know dave david johnson david
johnson
if we get the guy from three years ago
then maybe it's close to being the same
but i think that the losing hopkins is
too big i think they're going to be
worse
the big thing is though it might be a
positive and that desean watson and not
every big moment's just looking at one
guy the fact that the defense might have
to worry about more people that's kind
of why i said it but i mean listen
everything you also said you know you're
right no one's messing with hopkins so i
get that he's clearly better than
anybody there but i do think it's going
to make the offense a little more
versatile and tough to pin your ears
into one guy getting the ball
i don't know if if if your kids had a
security blanket when they were little
and you took it away it it wasn't the
easiest adjustment in the world and they
don't have a security blanket now for
desean watson all right last one real
quick vikings stefan diggs out justin
jefferson in
oh i'm going to say worse i love justin
jefferson i do but i mean i got to see
him play in the nfl before i start to
say it's going to be better than stefan
diggs i mean stefan diggs is one of the
better receivers in all of football we
know what he can do in the nfl he's a
difference maker you know justin
jefferson i expect him to be i think he
is he's not exactly the same type of
player as stefan diggs but i'm not going
to anoint him king over stefan diggs
until i see him do it on some sundays
first no matter how much i love this kid
coming out of college
and i agree with you we have to see him
prove himself it is a step back and and
it's going to fall on other guys i think
to pick up the slack while justin
jefferson learns the ropes irv smith jr
the tight end from alabama last year
that was the second round pick of the
vikings he's a guy to keep an eye on
they expect big things from him move him
out to the slot let him make some some
some things happen that way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports